مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
التغطيه المباشره والمستمره للاوضاع
المتلاحقه في السودان ففي اليوم السادس من
المواجهه المسلحه لا يزال طرفي الصراع
يتبادلان الاتهامات بخرق هدنه بدات هشه
وفشلت كسابقتها في حقن الدماء ووقف اطلاق
النار لليوم الثاني على التوالي وفي وقت
لا صوت يعلو على اصوات الرصاص المتبادله
هناك مخاوف من تفاقم الاوضاع الصحيه في
البلاد المنهكه بفعل ازمات سياسيه
واقتصاديه متتاليه منذ سنوات
وفي مواجهه بين قائدي الجيش والدعم السريع
لكن هذه المره اعلاميا حمل عبد الفتاح
البرهان قوات الدعم السريع التي يقودها
محمد حمدان دبلو الملقب بحميتي المسؤوليه
الكامله عن اعمال نهب الخرطوم او اعمال
نهب في الخرطوم ودارفور البرهان اكد في
تصريحات لصحيفه
ان جزءا كبيرا من قوه الدعم السريع خرجت
عن سيطره حميتي
وقال ان الانتقال الى المسار الديمقراطي
مرهون بهزيمه قوات حميد تيم ومن جهته وفي
تصريحات لفعنا تايمز ايضا اكد حميد تي ان
قوته لن تتراجع عن اهدافها حيث تعهد
بتقديم البرهان للمحاكمه حميدتي اوضح انه
منفتح على وقف اعمال العلف العنف لكنه
اشار الى ان البرهان لن يفعل الامر نفسه
متهما اياه بانه ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد نشر الجيش السوداني مقطع فيديو
يظهر سيطرته على قاعده الشفرليت في شمال
غربي البلاد والتي تعتبر من اكبر خطوط
الامداد لقوات الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
تم استلام معسكر الشفرليت التابع لقوات
الدعم السريع بعد ان قاموا هاربين منها تم
استلام عدد
اخلاء
وعدد واحد تنكر ماء وعدد جاك همر وكميه من
الاسلحه والزخاير
[موسيقى]
بفضله في هذه الساعه
وتم الاستيلاء على عدد خمسه
حريق في مهند للسلاح مهند للسلاح حريق في
الخرطوم اثنين شارع الصناعات شارع
الصناعات
العمارات اللي قاعده فوق وما قادر تطلع
فلوس قاعده فوق ما قادره تطلع حريق حريق
حريق من محل بتاع الذخيره
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه النداء استغاثه لاي زول بيعرف اي
جهه مطافي في اي جهه ممكن تيجي تتدخل في
الحته دي الناس المفروض تجي في الحته دي
فوق عالجه فوق وفي اطفال قاعدين فوق في
العماره والناس اللي ما قدرت اطلع
وفي ثلاثه ولا اكتر من اربع عمارات موجوده
تحت لبعض وهندي الناس حسك على التجريب
نداء استغاثه يا جماعه في اكتر من اربع
عمارات جنب بعض يفوز قاعده فوق ما قادره
تنزل
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بمهاجمه قواتها في ام درمان
مشيره الى تمكن قوتها من التصدي للهجوم
على تمركزاتها غرب المدينه اضافه القوات
عناصرها اسقطت مروحيتين للقوات الجويه
السودانيه كما اكدت على ما وصفته بالتزام
قوتها بالبقاء في مواقعها ووقف اطلاق
النار منذ اعلان الهدنه
حرب السلطه او الجنرلين دخلت يومها السادس
وفيما الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد المخاوف
من توسع رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار الدول
المجاوره ويزعزع عنها
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرتها طالما ان
الجنرالين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفوته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجيوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
معنى مشاهدينا من مدينه مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك يا نزار معنا
نزار صف لنا الوضع الميداني اذا في مروي
الان
نعم هذا هو اللي اليوم السادس للعمليات
العسكريه والاشتباكات التي بدات في
السودان شراره هذه الاحداث مروي كانت
مسرحا لنحو اربعه ايام من العمليات
العسكريه والاشتباكات الان مروي بعد ان
اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطرته كاملا على
محيط القاعده العسكريه وعلى مطار مروي
وعلى مركز القاعده الان هذا هو الشكل
الحياه ينقل حصريا على قناه العربيه في
هذه الصور المباشره من داخل مدينه مروي
الان حاله الهدوء النسبي تعم المدينه شرطه
المرور بدات في تنظيم حركه المواطنين
المواطنون كما تتابعون الان بداوا في
الوصول الى السوق الرئيس هذا السوق الذي
كان مغلقا لاكثر من ثلاثه ايام الان بدات
الحياه تعود الى طبيعتها كثير من
المواطنين الان بداوا في تلمس احتياجاتهم
بداوا في التبضع بدا وا في كثير من الامور
التي كانت بالنسبه لهم صعبه ولكنها الان
عاديه مرحب بك يا حاج
الحمد لله عاده لوضع الطبيعي وكل ما
نتمناه من القوى السياسيه ان تتماسك بيد
واحده وان لا تصطفل اي احد وان يضع مصلحه
السودان هي الاولويه بالنسبه لكل الشعب
السوداني
هذا احد الاصوات في مدينه مروي نحاول ان
نقترب اكثر ونتعرف على حجم الحياه وعلى
طبيعه الحياه وحجم التحرك في هذه المدينه
المواطنون الان يتحركون في هذه المدينه
باريحيه بعد ان انتشر الجيش السوداني وبعد
ان سيطره القوات المسلحه السودانيه على
مفاصل ومداخل المطار والقاعده وانتشرت في
معظم المناطق الجنوبيه في محليه مروي وفي
كريمه وغيرها سنحاول ايضا ان نقترب اكثر
لنستمع لافادات المواطنين وكيف يتابعون
هذه المرحله الجديده بعد انتشار الجيش
السوداني والقوات المسلحه كثير من
المواطنين حريصون ايضا على ايصال صوتهم
على طمانه اهلهم على طمانه اذويهم بان ما
حدث الان في مروي يمضي نحو الاستقرار
ويمضي نحو الهدوء احد المواطنين ايضا من
ابناء مروي يريد ان يوصل رسالته للعالم
عبر العربيه حول
الحدث وما يدور وكيف يتابع المواطنون في
مروي مجريات ما حدث خلال الساعات الماضيه
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام مرحبا كيف
الان نشرح للناس عايشين كيف في هدوء
الامور تمام والامور انجلت الحمد لله
والوضع مطمئن والناس زي ما شايفين انتم
السوق فاتح والناس يشتروا في حاجات العيد
والامور والحمد لله تمام كل الامور تمام
مطمنه يعني احنا حتى الناس اللي في البيوت
واللي كانوا طلعوا بره البيوت رجعوا
والحمد لله كل الامور تمام يعني متاكد حسب
معايشتك وحسب وجود سكان انه الناس اللي
كانوا خلال اليومين اللي فاتوا نزحوا من
مناطقم الان رجعوا رجع بيته رجع اهل
والحمد لله كل الامور مطمنه وانتم براكم
يعني حتى الامور يعني ما في اي مشكله ثاني
بعد الحمد لله احنا جيشنا ذاته الحمد لله
مسك مواقعه تمام وسلام محله تمام وثاني ما
في اي خوف وما في اي حاجه الحمد لله
الامور كلها تمام الحمد لله الله يجزيكم
خير بارك الله فيكم الله يسلمك هذا احد
المشاهد وهذا احد الاصوات في هذه المدينه
مدينه مروي تتابعون الان
حاله الشراء وحاله البيع مواطنون الان
وصلوا بعد ان اغلق هذا السوق سريا لاكثر
من اربعه ايام هذا هو اليوم الاول الذي
تدب فيه الحياه وتمضي كما كانت لا نقول ان
الامور عادت كما كانت بنسبه 100% ولكن
الحياه الان تمضي نحو نسبيه عاليه من
الهدوء من الاستقرار حالات البيع والشراء
تنذر بان المواطنين في هذه المنطقه الان
بداوا يستعودون شيئا من العافيه وشيئا من
الاستقرار وشيئا من الطمانينه هذه الصور
التي تتابعونها هي لمواطنين ارادوا ان
يستعدوا لفرحه العيد على الرغم من الاحزان
وعلى الرغم من وجود اصابات في صفوف
المدنيين وعلى الرغم ايضا من وجود اصابات
في صفوف القوات المسلحه السودانيه وعلى
الرغم ايضا من التداعيات التي خلفتها
الحرب والاشتباكات في هذه المدينه ولكنهم
حريصون على ان تكون الساعات المقبله هي
ساعات فرح على الاقل وان يتنسموا بعضا من
الفرح والطمانينه وهم الان يستعدون للشراء
احتياجاتهم خلال هذه الساعات بعد ان اعيد
افتتاح هذا مغلقا لسعد من هذه الشهادات
ومن نقلك لواقع الامور في مروي يمكن القول
بانه اذا لا توجد حتى اي جيوب لقوات الدعم
السريع في اي منطقه من مروي والسيطره
كامله وتامه للجيش السوداني في تلك
المنطقه
نعم هذا هذا ما تاكله الصور وهذا ما تؤكده
قرائن الحال وهذا ما يوقده الواقع الذي
نتابعه الان انتشار للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه انتشار للجيش حط الشرطه المدنيه
الان عادت الى تنظيم الشوارع وحركه المرور
هذه الامور كلها تؤكد ويؤمن عليها من قبل
الجيش الذي اكد لاكثر من مره للعربيه بانه
بسط سيطرته كامله على المطار وعلى القاعده
وعلى كل الحدود في هذه المنطقه وعلى
المواطنين الان ان يتصرفوا على سجيتهم
وعلى حريتهم وعلى طريقتهم وان الحياه
ستمضي وتعود وتيره الحياه كما كانت اف
السابق هذا هو الحال هذا هو صوت الشارع
هذه هي صوره الشارع في مروي بعد مرور سته
ايام على الاشتباكات وعلى العمليه
العسكريه التي بدات في مروي وامتدت لعدد
من مدن السودان على راسها العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
طيب شكرا جزيلا لك نزار بقداوي مراسل
العربيه كان معنا من مدينه مروي
في مروي ايضا والتي اتجهت الانظار اليها
على مدى الايام الماضيه حيث كانت الفتيل
الذي اندلعت منه الشراره الاولى للمواجهه
الراهنه بين الجيش وقوه دعم السريع فما
اهميه هذه المدينه التي تتمتع بخصوصيه
عسكريه
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز نصب على مطار المدينه للجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كيلومترا وهو مصمم
لاستيعاب هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه
بمهبط طائرات بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات
وعرض 60 مترا وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر
قوات الفرقه تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش
السوداني المسؤوله عن حمايه المرافق
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم بحري الصحفيه عمار
ابو شيبه اهلا بك استاذ عمار معنا استاذ
عمار
حبذا لو تضعنا في سوره الاوضاع الميدانيه
كيف تبدو الان في الخرطوم بحري تحديدا
يعني قبل قليل
ترد على طلعات للطيران
الحرب الذي كان يحلق قبل دقائق او لحظات
ربما هدات الان الاحوال لا نسمع اي اصوات
الارضيه بحسب المعلومات الميدانيه التي
ترد كل فتره وفتره ايضا ليس هنالك ربما
تحرك لقوات على الارض هي قوات تتحطم في
مناطق معينه اقصى شرق المدينه واقصى الغرب
باتجاه منطقه ام درمان وباتجاه منطقه
كافوري الحركه داخل الاحياء ايضا بحذر
رغبه المطابقه الارضيه ورغبه الطيران ما
زالت الحركه بحذر شديد نسمع ذوي مدافع
وقذائف من وسط العاصمه الخرطوم باعتبار
انها ليست بالبعيده من منطقه البحرين
طيب مناطق اخرى ايضا هل تشهد اشتباكات في
هذا اليوم السادس لبدء هذه المواجهه
العسكريه رغم يعني الحديث عن انه هذا
اليوم على ما يبدو اهداء يوم منذ اندلاع
هذه الازمه
يعني طلعنا قبل قليل بيان لقوه يقول بان
القوات المسلحه هجوم على معسكره في درمان
من مطره للرد على هذه الطلعات الحربيه
يعني هناك حديث عن اشتباكات في منطقه
الدرمان وهنالك اخبار ترد الان بان هناك
اشتباك في اولاد شمال كردفان فقط الابيض
هنالك اشتباك في هذه المدينه ومعروف ان
هذا الامتداد من وسط السودان الباهر يقودك
الى منطقه دارفور بشكل مباشر ربما حرب مدن
الان مفتوحه وهذا ما قال المرتبه الصحفي
للشرطه في ولايه الخرطوم الى انزال عديد
من النصائح المهمه فيما يخص حرب المدن
وتوعيه المواطنين بان يتخذوا الحيطه
والحذر وعديد من النصائح المهمه في مثل
حروب طيب ولكن يعني في هذه الاثناء كنا
قبل قليل تجولنا مع مراسلنا في مدينه مروي
راينا انه الحياه عادت
على طبيعتها نوعا ما في تلك المدينه او
وضع
الانساني والمدني كيف يبدو في العاصمه
الخرطوم
يعني انتظمت كثير جدا من الحملات
الاجتماعيه والانسانيه
تنتشر الان في الفضاء السفيري لكثير جدا
من الحالات الانسانيه وزاره الصحه ربما
صرحت بالامس لديكم بانها يعني ربما رجعت
الحياه الطبيعيه الى المستشفيات او تشغيل
المستشفيات رجع بنسبه 100% هذا لا يبدو
دقيقا بالمعنى صحيح لان حتى عمليه الوصول
للمستشفيات في منطقه اشتباك عسكري معروف
عند منطقه وسط الخرطوم والقياده العامه
للجيش ومطار الخرطوم هي تقع في وسط
الخرطوم مباشره وبها عبيد من المستشفيات
والمقر الصحيه وقبل ايام تم اجل عدد من
المرضى لعديد من المستشفيات الخاصه المرضى
الذين كان داخل هذه العيادات الطبيه
والمستشفيات شاهدنا بالفيديوهات مرضى قصير
الكلى كيف تم اخراجه من داخل هذه
المستشفيات الان علينا ان نشاهد وزاره
الصحه ان تنشر فيديوهات لهذه المستشفيات
تعمل طالما انها تقول بانها رجعت 100%
وحتى اذا ما تم هذا لابد ان تنشر مسارات
لطرق حتى تصل او يصل المواطن او اتصل
الحالات الانسانيه التي يعاني منها
المواطنون هنالك كثير من المناشدات في
الفضاء
الامراض المزمنه من السكري وما فيها ايضا
من اصابات بليغه يعني نعم طيب وضع كارث
الوضع المثالي
طيب عمار وده اسالك في اطار الحرب
الاعلاميه ما بين الجنرالالين والتي على
ما يبدو مسرحها هي الصحافه
العالميه عبد الفتاح البرهان تحدث وقال
بانه جزء كبير من قوه الدعم السريع خرجت
عن سيطره حميدتي
يعني هل هذا واضح
للعيان او هناك اشارات يعني واضحه
للمراقبين على ذلك
عبيد المراقبين والمحللين ربما العسكريين
يؤيدون هذا الاتجاه ولكن في الاتجاه
الثاني ربما يقول اخر بان المعركه دخلت في
يومها الثالث وان هذه القوات ما زالت تحصل
في مناطقها هذا يدخل ضد الحرب بين البيوت
في العراء لانه يعني معظم مقرات قوات
الدعم السريع تم ضربها وتدميرها
هذه المقرات تقدم دعم اللوجستي ودعم في
هذه القوات التي تتمركز داخل الاحياء
وبالقرب من البيوت بحسب ما نشر من
فيديوهاته بحسب ما نشاهد ولكن هذه القوات
تستطيع ان تتحصن بحكم المرونه العسكريه
وبحكم التكوين وعقيده هذه القوات هي في
الاصل اسمها قوات التدخل السريع تستطيع ان
تتدخل سريعا في عدد من المناطق وتتحصل
وتقدم مهام تنفذ مهام نوعيه هذا ما جعل
هذه القوات لديها قدره على التحصين وهذا
ربما يدخل ضمن الحرب النفسيه شاهدنا هذه
الحرب الاعلاميه ما بين القيادات وحتى
الجنود على ارض المعركه يصورون ويوافقون
ما يقوم به من انجازات عسكريه بحسب طبيعه
العمل العسكري في داخل المعركه
اذا ما دمروا
طائره او اذا سيطره قوات الجيش على مقر
القياده تصور ذلك يصور الجنود ذلك كانهم
مراكلون حربيين على ارض الواقع وتحولوا
للصح
افه ايضا هشاشه الوضع الموجود في منطقه
الاشتباك لان لا احد يسيطر بهذا الحديث في
البرهان كان قبل قليل لا احد يسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم يخرج الدعم السريع ويصرح بان
مازلنا نسيطر على هذا المطار وتنتشر
فيديوهات ويرد الجانب الاخر على الجانب
الاخر هذا يعكس باننا نمضي الى حرب ربما
فيها جانب نفسي وفيها جانب الاعلامي وفيها
جانب ايضا كذلك عسكريه يحسم ربما هذه
الاقاويل جميعها
شكرا جزيلا لك عمار ارجو ان تبقى معي
ساعود لك في سياق هذه الساعه
في متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع مشاهدينا
تحديدا تطورات احتجاز جنود مصريين في
السودان اكد المتحدث الرسمي للجيش المصري
اتخاذ كافه اجراءات التعاون والتنسيق مع
الاجهزه الامنيه السودانيه لتامين عوده
القوات المصريه الى بلادهم ولفت اي هبوط
ثلاث طائرات نقل عسكريه في احد مطارات
السودان حيث اغلت دفعه من القوات المصريه
او تم اخلائها وعادت بهم الى احدى القواعد
العسكريه الجويه بالقاهره واضاف المتحدث
العسكري انه تم تامين وصول باقي الجنود
المصريين لمقر السفاره تمهيدا لاجراءات
اخلائهم من السودان فور توفر الظروف
الامنيه المناسبه
في سياق اخر نفت القوه المسلحه الليبيه
بقياده خليفه حفتر تقديما دعم لطرف ضد
الاخر من طرفي الصراع الدائر في السودان
واوضح المتحدث باسم الجيش الوطني الليبي
احمد المسماري ان القوات المسلحه الليبيه
تقوم حاليا باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع
الاطراف المعنيه مضيفا ان القياده مستعده
للقيام بدوري الوساطه بين الاشقاء في
السودان لوقف القتال
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تدعو وتناسب بذروت الوقود الوقف
الفوري الاقتتال بين الاشقاء بدوله
السودان الشقيقه وعلى اهميه توفير الظروف
المناسبه للتحديه وتغليب المصلحه الوطنيه
العليا وانتهاز هذه الايام المباركه بحلول
عيد الفطر المبارك لوقف كافه الاعمال
العسكريه وذلك للمساهمه في استعاده
استقرار الاوضاع بالبلاد عبر التواصل
والتنسيق بين جميع الاطراف بغيت ايجاد
الارضيه المشتركه للتوافق والخروج من
الازمه الحاليه وتداعياتها محليا واقليميا
ودوليا وفي هذا الصدد فان القياده العامه
تنفي نفيا قاطعا ما تتناوله بعض وسائل
الاعلام الرخيصه
والمازوره بقيام القوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تقديم الدعم لط ضد الطرف الاخر بل
نحن كنا وما زلنا وسنظل مع استقرار دوله
السودان وامنها وسلامتها وسلامه شعبها
العربي الافريقي الاصيل وتقوم حاليا
باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع الاطراف
المعنيه وبيننا مستعدين للقيام بدور
الوساطه بين الاشقاء في السودان لوقف
القتال فورا وفتح المجال للحوار بالطرق
السلميه
معناها مشاهدينا من جنوب الخرطوم الصحفي
مدثر محمد اهلا بك منتصر معنا يعني بحسب
الاخبار التي تاتينا الان الاخبار العاجله
تجدد اطلاق النار وذويين في الجارات في
محيط القصر الجمهوري وجنوب مطار الخرطوم
وده اسالك عن التفاصيل الميدانيه كيف تبدو
الاوضاع تحديدا حيث انت
الاوضاع الميدانيه حيث انا في جنوب
الخرطوم الاوضاع هادئه في خلال الساعات
الماضيه
لم تحدث اشتباكات لم نستمع الى اي اصوات
اشتباكات هنا في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم كانت
هناك شبكات الصباح الباكر في منطقه جبره
ومنطقه ارض المعصره ولكن منذ
هنا الاوضاع هذه عاده الاوضاع
في المناطق المناطق السكنيه في جنوب
الخرطوم الى طبيعتها شيئا ما
نعم
استاذ مدثر
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال معه مشاهدينا
سنحاول اعاده الاتصال مره اخرى
طيب ما زلنا مع هذه الصور اذا البعض منها
مباشر وحيب كالتي نراها الان على الشاشه
يبدو انا بالفعل الوضع يتسم بالهدوء اذا
لم اكن مخطئه فيعني الصور التي
نراها الان هي لمطار الخرطوم اذا حيث
تحدثت الانباء عن دويا انفجارات في محيط
القصر الجمهوري وجنوب مطار الخرطوم على كل
حال عمار ابو شيبه ما زال معنا عمار
حدثنا اكثر عن ما يجري داخل المطار جنوب
مطار الخرطوم على ما يبدو يشهد اشتباكات
نحن نرى في الصوره ولكن يعني ليس واضحا ما
الذي يجري
هذه المنطقه منطقه جنوب الخرطوم ربما
هنالك حديث كان قبل قليل ومعلومات توفرت
قبل قليل عن تعزيزاته وتحركات لقوات الدعم
السريع وايضا التعزيزات التي وصلت الخرطوم
قبل يوم او يومين
بقوات الشعب المسلحه ربما هذه المنطقه
الان يجري فيها عمليه كسر عظم يعني معركه
كسر عظم بنسبه كبيره جدا جدا ونحن ندخل في
ساعات من الهدنه الهشه التي لم يلتزم بها
المتقاتلون على ارض الواقع هنالك فيما
يتعلق بالمطار المطار يخضع لصيدره سيطره
الجيش بشكل كامل ام هناك جيوب لقوات الدعم
السريع فيه
يعني الحديث تصريح قبل قليل للفاين للسيده
البرهان صرح بان المطار هذا الحديث نقل
ونشر يعني لان المطار لا يخضع للسيطره احد
قوات الدعم السريع ردت ربما من خلال عديد
من الاخبار بان هذا المطار ما زالت تسيطر
عليه وما زالت تتحكم فيه بنسبه كبيره هذه
المنطقه منطقه جنوب الخرطوم والمنطق التي
يقع فيها المطار وامتداداته الكثيره منطقه
كبيره جدا بحكم التخطيط الهندسي لمطار
الخرطوم فيمكن ان تكون هنالك الجيوب يمكن
ان يكون هناك تطويق من الجيش من الجانب
الشرقي
للمطار لشرق الجنوبي ونشاهد ايضا فيديوهات
نشرت قبل قليل الى ان هنالك مضادات في
منطقه حي الصفا المحاذيه لمطار الخرطوم
ولكن هل هناك طلعات جويه كثيفه يعني
يقوم بها الجيش السوداني
كانت قبل الطلعات الجويه كنا نسمع ذوي
المضادات الارضيه والمدافع ونسمع ايضا
كذلك الطيران الحربي الان لا نسمع
يعني صوت الطائره الحربيه ربما تعود بعد
قليل ربما هنالك خطه على المعركه في ارض
الميدان ومن ثم تعود او يعود الطيران
لاسناد القوات الارضيه والبريه التي تتحصل
ايضا من خلال
المعركه ومن خلال المطار وارض المطار
معروفه بها ارض شاسعه وواسعه يمكن للقوات
ان تتحرك ولكن مرونه قوات الدعم السريع في
التحرك السريع وفي التدخل والعوده ومن ثم
حرب كروه فر يعني كبيره طيب هل هل هناك
مناطق او مرافق مهمه تحت سيطره قوات الدعم
السريعه ام نتحدث عن جيوب عن قوات تتمركز
فيه ما بين الاحياء السكنيه تقوم
بهجمات ضمن
كر وفر وتعود مره اخرى
الذي نشر والذي نشاهده بان هذه القوات
تستطيع ان تتمركز وتتحصن او استقرت داخل
الاحياء بنسبه كبيره هذه القوات تحركت
بنسبه كبيره من منطقه شرق ووسط الخرطوم
ومنطقه وسط العاصمه اذا كذلك جعل هذه
القوات الان تطوق بنسبه كبيره داخل احياء
المربعات صغيره طوق منطقه المطار من
الناحيه الغربيه ومن الناحيه الشرقيه ايضا
كذلك الجيش نصر في كثير من المعلومات
وكثير من الفيديوهات بانه اعاد السيطره
على مواقع كانت تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم
السريع فيما يخص القياده العامه خاصه
في القوات البريه ومنطقه وزاره الدفاع
ومنطق وسط الخرطوم تشاهدين احيانا من خلال
الفيديوهات ان هناك اشتعال للنيران او
هنالك سحب للدخان وربما هذا حريق لبعض
المركبات ما بين الجانبين يبدو ان هناك
تدور معارك منطقه القصر الجمهوري كان هناك
حديث
بان القوات الدعم السريع تسيطر عليه
وهنالك فيديوهات نشرت لهم داخل هذه
المواقع ما يؤكد سيظهر على تلك المنطقه
وربما هنالك مدافع يعني اسمع مدافع ربما
اشتباكات الان على منطقه القصر الجمهوري
اسمع من منطقه البحر هذه المدافع ربما
هنالك اشتباك في هذه المنطقه باعتبارها
ايضا منطقه استراتيجيه وحساسه بالنسبه
للقوات المسلحه وبالنسبه للقوات الدعم
السريع
وفي تصريحات للعربيه ناشد المدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالمي احمد المنظر الاطراف
السودانيه الالتزام بالقوانين الدوريه
مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في السودان اكبر من
قدره الهيئات الصحيه
الاطراف المتنازعه الالتزام
بقانون الدولي المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه
ارواح المدنيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن
للاسف كما هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت
العقل خلال هذه المحن والازمات وانما يغلب
صوت السلاح للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع
داخل السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره
حتى يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم تعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان اسفرت عن
سقوط ضحايا من بينهم من يعمل في القطاع
الطبي والصحي
كالطبيبتين نجوى خالد حمد والاء فوزي
المرضي ولذين قتلتا برصاصه
خلال الازمات والحروب يكون الاطباء في
الصف الامامي لتقديم المساعده للمصابين
وفي حالات اخرى يكون هؤلاء الاطباء في
مرمى نيران المواجهات المسلحه
في السودان الامر لا يختلف اطباء راحوا
ضحايا للاقتتال المستمر الطبيبه نجوى خالد
حمد اصيبت بطلق ناري اثناء عودتها للمنزل
ما ادى لوفاتها الى جانب الطبيبه الاء
فوزي المرضي التي قتلت اثر رصاصه طائشه
والصيدلي ابو ذر محمد زين الذي اردته
نيران الاشتباكات المسلحه قتيلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه
مخاوف انهيار الوضع الصحيبي بشكل كامل ليس
المشكله الوحيده الان هناك ازمه مياه في
الخرطوم تتفاقم ايضا بعد مرور اكثر من
خمسه ايام على انقطاعها بالكامل عن معظم
المناطق السكنيه في الخرطوم حيث يعيش
السودانيون في ظروف صعبه بسبب انقطاع
المياه والكهرباء معا وما زادت من
معاناتهم ايضا نقص الغذاء وشح الخدمات
الاساسيه في ظل استمرار الاشتباكات البحر
ولا كهرباء طيب زي ما شايفين انه
المواطنين الان الرجاء استخدموا الابارات
الجوفيه والمعاناه كبيره جدا حراره مرتفعه
وانقطاع الكهرباء ما بين فتره واخرى وانتم
كثير جدا من الاحياء والمربعات المجاوره
رجل لنفس الاتجاه والمنطقه بقت منطقه
الناس بيكونوا موجودين فيها وبياخدوا منها
المياه الجوفيه وهي مياه برضه مش صالحه
للشرب غدر ما هي ممكن يتم استخدامها في
اشياء ثانيه
في تداعيات هذا الصراع المسلح تتزايد
موجات النزوح في السودان ففي شمال شرق
السودان وبالتحديث بورد سودان بدات
الشوارع خاليه الا من بعض الاشخاص الذين
حملوا امتعتهم وفروا من القتال الدائر
الحاليه في مدينه بورسودان امنه
وقديش السوداني يسيطر لجميع قوات الدعم
السريع والامن مستتب في البحر الاحمر
والشعب السوداني في امن واماني يعني
الحركه مستمر والسوق الحمد لله نطمنكم
تمارين فاتح والمواطنين المتسوق الحد
الساعه واحده ليلا ونتمنى انه السوداني
يعم الخير والسلام
هذا ولم يسلم الاطفال من هذه المواجهات
حيث قتلت قذيفه ظلت طريقها ثلاثه اطفال
سودانيين شقيقان وابن وابن خالتهما اللذين
راحه ضحيه الاشتباكات
اسلحه القتال لا تفرق بين الرجال والنساء
ولا حتى بين الكبار والصغار تحصد ارواح كل
من تجد في طريقها محمد بابكر ومعتز بابكر
وابن خالتهما منذر عوض ثلاثه اطفال كانوا
مشغولين باللعب تحت شجره قرب منزلهم في
منطقه الجريف بالعاصمه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
قبل ان تسقط عليهم قذيفه وتنهي حياتهم
فورا جراء الاشتباكات المتواصله بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وفي ماساه اخرى قتل المؤذن عباس سالم
برصاصه طائشه انهت حياته قرب مسجد كوبر في
منطقه بحري بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ليكون احد ضحايا الاقتتال داير في هذا
البلد سالم الذي خرج ذاهبا الى المسجد لم
يكن يعلم انه لن يعود مره ثانيه الى اهله
في الحرب كل شيء متوقع لا تكون حياه
المقاتلين في ساحه المعركه مهدده فقط بل
كل المحيطين قد يكونون في مرمى رصاصه
طائشه
عباس سالم احد مؤذني مسجد كوبر في منطقه
بحر بالعاصمه الخرطوم لم يكن يعلم انه
سيكون هدفا لمواجهه هو ليس طرفا فيها
طلقه طائشه انهت حياته امام المسجد
ليضاف الى قائمه طويله من ضحايا المواجهات
في السودان
[موسيقى]
كنا متوقع ان يكون هذا اليوم هو الاهدى
انه كل ما ارتفعت سمسم النهار وزادت سخونه
هناك على ارض الميدان وسيده المعارك سخونه
حيث ان المعلومات تشير الان الى معارك
بيترا وتدور في البحر وفي ام درمان فاذا
الامر يبدو انه ان كان اهدى نسبيا من
الايام الصادقه ولكنه ايضا هذا خلق واضح
للهدنه وعدم التزام من الطرفين بالخدمه
التي لمده 24 ساعه رغم محاوله المواطنين
يعني محاوله استعاده بالحياه الطبيعيه في
بعض الاحياء التي هي تبعد نحوي مصادر الى
20 كيلو من دائره الاحداث ودون يعني
التقيد بما يجري من اجراءات وقيود امنيه
الان السوداني يعني من لا مما هناك اسر
عاشت اوضاع انسانيه او صعبه انا قبل قليل
كنت اتحدث مع احد
العالقين داخل داخل احد الابراج بالقرب من
دائره دائره دائره الاشتباكات الرئيسيه
لقبل من القياده العامه قال انهم منذ خمسه
ايام لم يعني يتحصل على الماء الا عشيره
الامس فقط وكان بحتهم قليل من الماء يعني
يعني حتى بعد الافطار اقول له هم حوالي
سته وسبعه في الشده كله احد يعني ياخذ
جرعه وحيده ويكتفي بها وهم في الصيام فاذا
يعني يبدو ان الان وتيره الاشتراكات تبدو
في التصاعد في ظل يعني تواجد الدعم
الصليبي في عدد من الاحياء في محيط
القياده العامه يبدو ان ان التصري هذا
الذي اطلقها عبد الفتقاع البرهان ومحمد
حمدان قبل قليل يعني ستزيد من سخونه
المعارك غيلان تمسكا باستمرار في الحرب
وكل منهم يقول ان الميدان سيحدد النتيجه
النهائيه وهذا امر مؤسف دوره مراعاه
للاوضاع الانسانيه ودون يمكن ان تقود هذه
الحرب من
السودانيين شكرا جزيلا لك خالد الفكي
الصحفي كان معنا من الخرطوم مشاهدينا ما
زلنا مع هذه التغطيه الحيه والمباشره في
الاخبار
العاجله التي تاتينا الان اذا الصحه
العالميه تقول رصدنا مقتل 330 شخصا واصابه
3200 اخرين جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
طبعا هذه الارقام هي اعلى من الارقام التي
اوردتها المصادر السودانيه فيما يتعلق
بهؤلاء الضحايا على كل حال الدنمارك و
هولندا اعلنت انهما سيشتريان 14 دبابه من
طراز
اثنين لارسالها الى اوكرانيا طبعا هذا في
بعض الاخبار المتفرقه خارج اطار ما يجري
في السودان
وهذه الانباء او هذا الاعلان ياتي بحسب
بيان لوزاره الدفاع الدنماركيه اوضحت
الوزاره ان دبابات تسلم اعتبارا من مطلع
2024 مشيره الى ان الكلفه تقدر
ب165 مليون يورو
سيتقاسمهم البلدان مناصفه في بيان اخر رات
وزاره الدفاع الهولنديه ان امنع اوكرانيا
وامن اوروبا متلازما
الى اوكرانيا في اول زياره له الى كييف
منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا وجاءت هذه
الزياره التي تندرج ضمن مساعي الحلف
لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا في الوقت الذي تساعد
فيه لجن هجوم مضاد في وقت سابق هذا الشهر
دعست الرئيس الاوكراني
الى قمه للحلف تعقد في يوليو المقبل
مازلنا معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المباشره والمفتوحه منذ سته ايام لاحداث
السودان طبعا وهذه تغطيه ستستمر معكم في
الساعات القادمه لنقل كل جديد مما يجري في
السودان اشكر لكم حسن المتابعه والى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات